now we've been talking quite a lot on
the show about marcus rashford's free
school meal campaign it's something the
children's commissioner
and longfield has got some pretty strong
feelings about she joins us now thank
you very much for being with us so
do you think the government should
provide free school meals for children
over the holidays
i think they should um i've been
horrified
um by the debate and really disappointed
about the debate
over recent days we're a wealthy country
um it's 2020
and have a debate about whether we
should uh make sure that hungry and
vulnerable children should have enough
to eat
is something which is strikingly similar
in chapters
i think of you know what we'd expect
seeing oliver oliver twist
a novel published in the 19th century so
let's stop the divisive and distracting
conversations and start focusing
i think we all have to agree now there's
a problem there's a problem with
children going hungry in this country
and there's a problem with children in
poverty
and we need now knowing that to focus on
what that solution is
at the same time though the government
would argue that the welfare system is
there to help parents uh who need
uh more income in a way that it wasn't
really
in dickens's time they're also saying of
course that providing
this would cost money and do you think
that they have a point
well of course we do have a welfare
system uh it needs to work better for
those
uh poor families and we need to make
sure we have more support
in place for those poor families the
majority of which are working
but there's also a pandemic going on so
we entered the pandemic
knowing there are about a third of all
children were living in poverty there'd
be children waking up this morning and
not having food
in the cupboards do we really want that
to be the case um
but also it's increasing because we know
that there's
people all the time families who are
facing
unemployment so this isn't going to go
away
now i'm told that the pm understands
this i'm told that there are people
around him
having positive discussions about this
we've had very good
suggestions from robert halford about
breakfast the dimbleby proposals around
food and activities are still there
so i want this stem to move from
something which is a possibility and a
discussion
to something which is real and the clock
is ticking
we need to ensure that those families
and children have the confidence that
they're going to have food on the table
we're out of step with the rest of the
uk and we need to make sure that
free school meals it isn't the long-term
solution
but are available not only at christmas
but up until april
like the rest of the uk um i'm
interested in what you make of some of
the
political reaction because it's kicked
off a bit of a storm hasn't on social
media and the conservative mp ben
bradley
tweeted about two children in his
constituency saying one lives in a
crackdown another in a brothel
these are the kids that most need our
help extending free school meals doesn't
reach these kids
he then replied to a tweet in which the
other user said
twenty pound cash direct to a crackden
and a brothel really sounds like the way
forward with this one
and ben bradley said that's what free
school me free school
meal vouchers in the summer effectively
did
what did you make of that exchange well
i think that's deeply disrespectful as
uh i think many of the residents of
mansfield have said
um look we should be proud of providing
that level of support for vulnerable
children i think most people are
there are other ways that we can do this
we can look at putting money onto child
benefit we can look at increasing
universal credit all of those things
that need to happen but to say
make that kind of comment i think is
deeply disrespect
disrespectful and if there are children
living in dangerous situations in his
constituency
he should be calling the local authority
and social services to make sure that
those children get help
rather than going on to twitter to talk
about it so again
distraction let's look at what are the
problems and let's look at how we can
help children
have a better opportunities now food on
the table
and also get numbers in poverty down
i'm keen to touch on mental health as
well it's something we were talking
about with dr rosenna allen khan too
um are you concerned about the impact
that lockdown
and the social restrictions are having
on the mental health of children
well kids have found this really tough
um you know all their normal routine
um was kind of taken from under their
feet overnight when schools closed back
in march
and you know for kids time's different
it feels like a lifetime for us but
for them you know this could be a large
portion of their experience
um as they've been growing up they don't
know what's going to come they don't
know what's
ahead uh we've seen that there's high
levels of stress in children
during the pandemic and actually a third
of all children saying they're worried
about their future they don't know what
their prospects will be
and there were some really alarming
figures out this week from actually the
nhs and ons
that showed that now one in six children
are probably
have a mental health condition now
that's a huge
number of children in any classroom at
any time
before the pandemic simon stephens the
head of the nhs called
children's mental health an epidemic
well it's getting worse because of the
pandemic so
i want to see a really robust response
from that from government in their
spending review
i want to see a mental health counselor
in every school part and parcel
parcel of life for kids so they can get
the help when they need it
really concerning of course another big
concern
during the last months and year has been
the number of children who've missed out
on so much of their education
because of schools being closed um now
we're in a situation where
many families are seeing their schools
being sent home for
their children being sent home for two
weeks if someone in the whole year group
has tested positive
do you think the rules on school bubbles
need to change so that our children can
spend longer periods at school
so i've argued for a long time to get
kids back into school so
uh september was a relief the numbers
overall
uh are good nine out of ten kids in
school and most schools still
um open fully but of course when there
are outbreaks and
you know there are going to be more of
those we have to live with this
there has to be a sensible way to manage
it now i've been speaking to public
health england this week about the rules
and the guidance
around the number of children that are
sent at home
when there are outbreaks the guidance
from education department for education
say
a small number around the child but
sometimes that gets lost in translation
and whole year groups
go ascent home now of course you know we
have to be safe and sensible about this
but we need to get that right so that
children aren't being sent home
unnecessarily and the other part of that
of course when they're at home
they need to carry on being able to
learn there needs to be good remote
education
and um and
lessons online but also they need to
have the laptops and techs there
and not all children have that yet so
again great
urgency about getting that into place